sean fchi funciones que toman valores
reales y que están definidas en el
intervalo 01 cerrado es decir le ponemos
estos corchetes
cuando pensamos que la función también
está definida en 0 y en 1 es decir en
los extremos y ahora estas funciones
están definidas por fx igual a la equis
cuadrada más a la menos x cuadrada que x
es x por x por ea la x cuadrada más a la
menos x cuadrada y hdx es x cuadrada por
ea la x cuadrada más sea la menos x
cuadrada ahora si a b y c son los
máximos absolutos de f g y h
respectivamente en 01 entonces a es el
máximo de f b es el máximo de g
es el máximo de h entonces nos ofrecen
cuatro opciones para ver si son iguales
distintos y combinaciones de ese estilo
entonces vamos a vamos a tratar de
explicar esto y realmente lo que tenemos
que notar es que estas funciones
difieren por un coeficiente aquí tenemos
un equis y aquí un equis cuadrada y
podemos pensar que aquí f tiene un 1
verdad entonces el coeficiente de fg y h
que que está antes de la equis cuadrada
cambia en este caso es 1 aquí es x ya
que es x cuadrada ahora el resto de la
función es exactamente igual entonces
vamos a ver qué pasa con esto en el
intervalo 01 que ya estamos en el
intervalo 01 cerrado verdad entonces lo
que sí sabemos es que como tenemos algún
número digamos x que es más chico que 1
entonces x cuadrada será menor o igual
que x y que x es menor o igual que 1
verdad esta desigualdad la podemos
obtener de esta otra
no nos debería poner eso parece un igual
esta desigualdad si la multiplicamos por
x como es un número mayor o igual que 0
nos quedaría x cuadrada menor o igual
que lo cual nos da esta desigualdad de
acá y bueno creo que con eso nos basta
ahora lo que viene es ver qué pasa con
estos coeficientes si x cuadrada es más
chica que x y que es más chico o igual
que 1 entonces quiere decir que como
todo lo demás es igual
efe x o más bien debería empezar por hdx
hdx tiene aquí el coeficiente x cuadrada
que es más chico que los otros entonces
en general la función va a ser menor o
igual que x y gx tiene un x que es más
chico o igual que 1 entonces esto será
menor o igual que fx muy bien entonces
vamos ahora a ver como como como ver
esto
qué pasa cuando si nos tomamos efe vamos
a hacer todo el análisis ene efe primero
que pasa cuando f toma valores en 0
entonces si sustituimos en 0 tenemos a
la 0 que es 1 esto es uno más era la
menos 0 que es que a la cero que es uno
entonces tenemos que efe de cero es uno
más uno y es 2
ahora quienes f1 efe de uno pues es que
a la 1 que es más que a la menos 1 era
la menos uno o lo que es lo mismo uno
entre y muy bien entonces si nos damos
cuenta
efe de uno esto es el que es dos punto y
algo de esto es más grande que dos y
además le agregamos algo más más grande
que cero verdad algo algo positivo que
tenga un exponente negativo no significa
que sea negativo sino que esto es uno
entre y como es positivo pues entonces
esto de hecho es más grande que 2
entonces más o menos más o menos
podríamos ir
bueno acomodando todo esto en una
gráfica de la siguiente forma aquí en
cero decimos que vale 2 aquí estamos en
2 y aquí estamos parados después en 1 sí
aquí está el 1 entonces esto vale más el
perdón y más a la menos 1
por acá tendrá este valor muy bien
tenemos este valor y ahí tenemos a más 1
entre 1 entre x y ala menos uno
entonces si considerábamos sólo estos
dos valores de entrada en 0 es más chico
que en 1 verdad en 1 vale esto que está
acá arriba entonces de un primer vistazo
es un primer vistazo este tal vez podría
ser un candidato a tener el valor máximo
verdad pero tenemos que ver cómo se
comporta la función si hiciera algo así
si la función hiciera algo así bueno
pues entonces podríamos decir que f
alcanza su máximo en 1 pero qué tal que
esta función hace cosas más alocadas
como por ejemplo algo así verdad
entonces si toma este tipo de forma la
función pues aquí no es un máximo no es
un máximo entonces para para identificar
este tipo de comportamiento lo que
tenemos que hacer es calcular la
derivada y sabemos que la derivada es la
pendiente de la recta tangente en cada
punto verdad si sabemos que la derivada
se anula en algún lugar entonces ahí hay
un máximo o un mínimo
pero por ejemplo si la derivada siempre
fuera positiva quiere decir que la
función siempre decrece y entonces
tendríamos el caso que les había
comentado verdad si siempre crece se ve
así y entonces tendríamos un máximo en
uno pero bueno vamos a ver en realidad
cómo se ven estas cosas vamos a ver
calculamos la derivada y tenemos que la
derivada de f en cualquier punto x es
igual
vamos a esto y utilizamos la regla de la
cadena derivamos la exponencial que es a
la equis cuadrada por la derivada de x
cuadrada que es 2x y ahora sumamos la
derivada de ea la menos x cuadrada que
es la menos x cuadrada por la derivada
de menos x cuadrada que es menos menos 2
x entonces vamos a quitar este y vamos a
ponerle
- 2x muy bien entonces esto es la
derivada y pues vayamos podemos esto
arreglarlo un poco por ejemplo si factor
izamos un 2x y un ala menos x cuadrada
ok entonces tú dirás al aquí no hay no
hay una ala menos x cuadrada no pero si
nosotros multiplicamos o bueno como le
hacemos para que al multiplicar por él a
menos x cuadrada me quede la x cuadrada
pues eso es que a la 2x cuadrada verdad
si multiplicamos los exponentes se suman
y entonces tenemos 2x cuadrada menos
equis cuadrada es x cuadrada muy bien y
ahora aquí pues es justamente este
factor así que sólo nos queda un -1 y ya
factor izamos de esta forma si nos damos
cuenta el primer en este primer factor
este de aquí es siempre mayor o igual
que cero porque x está en el intervalo 0
1 y eso siempre es mayor o igual que 0
exponencial de cualquier número no
importa el que sea siempre es mayor o
igual que 0 otra vez si aquí hay un
exponente negativo no significa que sea
negativo significa que es el inverso
multiplicativo de la equis cuadra pero
bueno entonces la pregunta que nos queda
es bueno como es la derivada de este
factor será mayor o igual que 0 o será
menor o igual a veces cambia agua veo
quién sabe qué pasa bueno vamos a ver
eso tenemos a la 2 x al cuadrado menos 1
la pregunta es si esto es mayor o igual
que 0 bueno pero eso es equivalente a
preguntarnos si es a la 2x cuadrada es
mayor o igual que una verdad sumando uno
de ambos lados será cierto esto pero si
sacamos logaritmo natural de ambos lados
que podemos hacerlo
esto es 2x cuadrada mayor o igual que el
logaritmo natural de uno que es cero
pero este sí es cierto porque 2 es
positivo bueno si de hecho 2 es positivo
x es mayor o igual que 0 por lo tanto x
cuadrada
entonces esto siempre va a ser mayor o
igual que 0 entonces lo que tenemos es
que toda esta expresión que es la
derivada toda esta expresión es siempre
siempre va a ser mayor o igual que 0
pero en el intervalo 01 verdad cerrado
entonces ya lo tenemos entre 0 y 1 aquí
está el 0 y acá está el 1 tenemos que
nuestra función en realidad se dibuja
más o menos
de esta forma muy bien siempre va
creciendo y por lo tanto nos está
diciendo muchísimo esto porque está este
valor
efe de 1 es justamente nuestro valor
máximo no hay otro que tenga un valor
mayor verdad entonces podemos decir que
esto se da que justamente
como a es el máximo de esto pues efe
siempre va a ser menor o igual que a
verdad entonces podemos todavía decir
más porque necesitamos decir cómo es hg
con respecto de a es decir como son los
máximos de h y de g bueno eso es algo
muy fácil de ver notemos que que si
evaluamos que en 1 recordemos quiénes g
qué es esto entonces esto será 1 verdad
1 por ea la 1 1 por más que a la menos
uno sea la menos uno perfecto entonces
esto si nos damos cuenta es justamente
lo que vale
efe en uno pero efe en uno es justamente
nuestro valor a esto es justamente a
también tenemos que h en uno pues si
sustituimos esto es 1 al cuadrado que es
1 por qué más a la menos 1 y esto
también es a entonces fíjense muy bien
el argumento lo que estoy diciendo
entonces es que que los máximos
absolutos de g y h también son a por lo
siguiente h y que no pueden pasar de a
por qué pues porque f no podía pasar de
a a es el valor máximo que puede tener f
pero f es más grande que estos dos
entonces hg no pueden pasar de a eso es
un primer punto y el segundo es que en
uno justamente vale nada entonces eso es
lo que me dice que éste es
máximo absoluto entonces aquí esto
podemos decir que es el máximo de g y
esto es el máximo de h entonces espero
que hayas encontrado esto muy útil y que
al menos también hayas podido repasar un
poco de criterios de la primera derivada
y de la primera derivada para encontrar
máximos de funciones